[Music]
India Kaiser Frankie kuzu
Ron dunya messages are a better man a
yatta kappa come here apostasy silla
scholars wanna Baltic jerónimo de madera
media Kashmir see who America a
sovereign casbah remember secretive
Arikara mania bleep man EKGs variably
boxes medicated such a car proper time
it's a Frankie full duty which is a
practical time yet among seasoned [ __ ]
among policy logic fully we are
politically you attain the optimum to
superpower ITF March April May whisper
Kazan idea
katha Sujata October Mubarak yes but
he'll also nicely voltage requirement a
villain Darko subsequent about two
hundred Tina's arpita's grahame-bishop
other canoes arancini Sookie's a Frankie
D which is to buffoon killer idea
monomania ties muhammara kashmir moved
out from one district Miata
Kiran compar malate or share a cynical
de Sucre co-team ratio day is May 8
torment is apparently surety Rajab is
October kuru Jota to whom bikini car gar
quesadilla pedigree catapulted a diamond
sutra temple l-jamaa kirk a busy day
the pranky tester eTCO da yo mama salumi
garam masala - TK make a parameter value
Makati and attack enemy Chile or Peru
sticky limited a kimochi so vagenda
Srinivasa T mr. Teske Mara sarah
diarmuid se para or the world behave
Mukhopadhyay risky
[Music]
Safran beluga caviar truffles and bonnet
potatoes are just some of the world's
most expensive foods weight potatoes is
that right guys it says here on the
script potatoes potato seriously
welcome to nor Monte air a tighly island
off the Atlantic coast of France this is
the only place you can find the king of
potatoes His Majesty love bomb note but
if you want to eat them fresh you've got
to be quick as they're only available
for 10 days a year this is Rudy he's a
potato farmer so what makes the island
of Monte heir so special for these Smuts
sedessa music videos for premium
[Music]
ah sweet little girl is a porter Anatole
no at all I'm only supplement right
there if you calculate the new
definition all the farmers on the island
apart of cooperative they do with
treating cleaning selling and sending
all over Europe Nicolas is the director
he makes sure everything runs smoothly
he really loves these potatoes
Department Odie Odie de la primera
Bernard annuity hello voila sorry hello
le fragile nipa mechanism sipoc Saco do
sombrio
de l'homme Salama like I called Aleppo
not Sofia dustman de la ville serve a
unique most of the jewel now I hope
you're sitting down because in 1996
these pricey potatoes fetch the auction
an insane amount drumroll roughly $500
per pound
luckily for you and me nowadays bonnet
potatoes aren't gonna break the bank
fetching more like five dollars per
pound which is still a lot for a bag of
potatoes sail upon the television or
see a unison total my Zetas have a
artisanal they don't liquidity associate
unfair since kion face rather long world
Alfonso T table table a pass to Apollo
viju we will assist you
Don appearing across is only one table
[Music]
once the harvest is complete an annual
bonnet festival is held here the golden
potatoes are traditionally served with
grilled sardines so Halliday tastes see
soprano routine pon de tarabuco
ago a sefer from the Terre des hommes
you were in severe shipping a manner was
moshpit emoji rigor llamo Christina
Pahang coup d'etat who may own if a pan
of the dual comp Lizzie her don't
collect easily so there we have it the
king of potatoes
thank you your majesty additional watt
McGraw technical Peeta new yes a red
Capricia aqua nest Oh a red curry add in
an estate was valued especially the
probably very good boy max level and
seems you're easily observed magnetic
black
[Music]
sixteen years ago Slobodan Simas bought
a dozen donkeys his herd has since grown
to nearly 300 but hundreds of donkeys
doesn't necessarily mean gallons of
donkey milk
unlike cows or goats donkeys produced
milk in very small quantities while
nursing their fall
oh no Sammy Allah says a PETA was a shto
named a sea route margaret segment
videos in the tone eco news for the
president so we tried to make cheese
from his donkey milk but it turns out
that process was far from simple
problems problem see you tomorrow on
grazie Mille a con named adobo no
kazarina
Pulu Jesus gross nominee malaika so he
keeps his methods a secret that Edom do
go tram process Petra ji o drezna tiny
yamaha dresnok problem aqua drug eluding
insulation toy or Nostromo gujarati she
would deny reggie in high school me try
Newton's melody Niko is namana privately
see Rod Magazine when the cheese goes
for around $500 a pound and it has a
rich nutty and earthy flavor it is known
to be quite filling but just a select
few have tasted it you can only get
donkey cheese in Serbia in the post ome
cocoa a proba or Dionisio diatone esto
los not together Sinestro strap or 7 or
in store name and a druggy mastema
your Bertram Baba Chakradhar let's go
[Music]
if you want a pastrami sandwich go to
class today me if you want to chat to
you come to hide each day this my
friends is the story of the real New
Yorkers sandwich and the people who keep
the legacy alive
I've been each year for 20 years any
tourists in the world enjoy the hot
doggies but all you New Yorkers know in
the chat pieces 110th and 1st Avenue
inside the bodega best known as Hajis we
meet Salah my name is Salah I Habashi
I'm the manager of Hajis Dillon grocery
for 50 minutes we actually invented chap
cheese your boss so they get to chop see
where everything on it let us take you
to the ingredients is one burger for
example or two burgers you chop it up
good and you put it with some scissors
that's the secret decision and whatever
you like like lettuce tomatoes onion
that's Sanders is an Arabic food what we
don't add cheese over there but when we
come here we do cheese only on a roll is
375 on a hero that's cost like five
dollars
Hajis is located in a part of New York
that's made up of various kinds of
people with a variety of incomes so
keeping chopped cheese at a price point
everyone can afford has been a top
priority in fact the chopped cheese has
only gone up a dollar in the last decade
we are here for wrong time helping the
community and serving the community
Geoff cheese is like everything to the
community because it's affordable and
delicious so everybody liked it we sell
about 200 escaped cheeses and a cosplay
of the chopped cheese has spread beyond
Harlem and into bodegas far and wide
attracting oil New Yorkers everywhere it
appears but in the end it all comes back
to Hajis and Salah the chap cheese
everything but for me sometimes I don't
need to achieve
I make it like a chap Hamburg is the
same thing but no cheese I'm trying to
lose weight that's all
[Music]
what allow me killing chickens Oh potato
self an angle-theta produce and a little
[Music]
Washington CEO Han Ming Russia with
three years solid forces hie and Elaine
Cheng hua tariqa or insouciantly
championship or like Singapore National
Congress has read that sahaja yogi
super-pan pursue she searches and some
pizza shop we will travel over to trader
2003 so a massive crisis the intuitive
as a loggia
voila Oh chi-su young-ran channel
Shantou Chanel higher wattage and Tyler
too slouchy the Sangha nitrogen Gao Qi
de ver si yo insulin cases Georgia fan
Toraja Botox event or - the mentor canto
cuca tomatoes even to Tibetans in Yong
Chan New Mexico who do I see okay me
were maintained as a family man ke my
tau if I totaled yogi the sources may
chilling to un like water
self-enhancement way like a sewer water
Tom a healing sentencing sir on the
surface of the launching we can widen
the
and rousing the job at zola but you know
what honey
oh yes doubt each head toshiaki kawada
so Otaru lhasa watt rating chong linghu
chong a psychological meat tenderizer
yeah well hi so young Jackson major
water damage healing is in surah so
whole water suddenly turn attract and
that email and subtitle for Susan's even
a condolence since a woman
json-based he releasing Waseem
[Music]